For the rest of the term,
we are going to be studying not
just one differential equation
at a time, but rather what are
called systems of differential
equations.
Those are like systems of
linear equations.
They have to be solved
simultaneously,
in other words,
not just one at a time.
So, how does a system look when
you write it down?
Well, since we are going to be
talking about systems of
ordinary differential equations,
there still will be only one
independent variable,
but there will be several
dependent variables.
I am going to call,
let's say two.
The dependent variables are
going to be, I will call them x
and y, and then the first order
system, something involving just
first derivatives,
will look like this.
On the left-hand side
will be x prime,
in other words.
On the right-hand side will be
the dependent variables and then
also the independent variables.
I will indicate that,
I will separate it all from the
others by putting a semicolon
there.
And the same way y prime,
the derivative of y with
respect to t,
will be some other function of
(x, y) and t.
Let's write down explicitly
that x and y are dependent
variables.
And what they depend upon is
the independent variable t,
time.
A system like this is going to
be called first order.
And we are going to consider
basically only first-order
systems for a secret reason that
I will explain at the end of the
period.
This is a first-order system,
meaning that the only kind of
derivatives that are up here are
first derivatives.
So x prime is dx over dt
and so on.
Now, there is still more
terminology.
Of course, practically all the
equations after the term
started, virtually all the
equations we have been
considering are linear
equations, so it must be true
that linear systems are the best
kind.
And, boy, they certainly are.
When are we going to call a
system linear?
I think in the beginning you
should learn a little
terminology before we launch in
and actually try to start to
solve these things.
Well, the x and y,
the dependent variables must
occur linearly.
In other words,
it must look like this,
ax plus by.
Now, the t can be a mess.
And so I will throw in an extra
function of t there.
And y prime will be some
other linear combination of x
and y, plus some other messy
function of t.
But even the a,
b, c, and d are allowed to be
functions of t.
They could be one over t cubed
or sine t
or something like that.
So I have to distinguish those
cases.
The case where a,
b, c, and d are constants,
that I will call --
Well, there are different
things you can call it.
We will simply call it a
constant coefficient system.
A system with coefficients
would probably be better
English.
On the other hand,
a, b, c, and d,
this system will still be
called linear if these are
functions of t.
Can also be functions of t.
So it would be a perfectly good
linear system to have x prime
equals tx plus sine t times y
plus e to the minus t squared.
You would never see something
like that but it is okay.
What else do you need to know?
Well, what would a homogenous
system be?
A homogenous system is one
without these extra guys.
That doesn't mean there is no t
in it.
There could be t in the a,
b, c and d, but these terms
with no x and y in them must not
occur.
So, a linear homogenous.
And that is the kind we are
going to start studying first in
the same way when we studied
higher order equations.
We studied first homogenous.
You had to know how to solve
those first, and then you could
learn how to solve the more
general kind.
So linear homogenous means that
r1 is zero and r2 is zero for
all time.
They are identically zero.
They are not there.
You don't see them.
Have I left anything out?
Yes, the initial conditions.
Since that is quite general,
let's talk about what would
initial conditions look like?
Well, in a general way,
the reason you have to have
initial conditions is to get
values for the arbitrary
constants that appear in the
solution.
The question is,
how many arbitrary constants
are going to appear in the
solutions of these equations?
Well, I will just give you the
answer.
Two.
The number of arbitrary
constants that appear is the
total order of the system.
For example,
if this were a second
derivative and this were a first
derivative, I would expect three
arbitrary constants in the
system --
-- because the total,
the sum of two and one makes
three.
So you must have as many
initial conditions as you have
arbitrary constants in the
solution.
And that, of course,
explains when we studied
second-order equations,
we had to have two initial
conditions.
I had to specify the initial
starting point and the initial
velocity.
And the reason we had to have
two conditions was because the
general solution had two
arbitrary constants in it.
The same thing happens here but
the answer is it is more
natural, the conditions here are
more natural.
I don't have to specify the
velocity.
Why not?
Well, because an initial
condition, of course,
would want me to say what the
starting value of x is,
some number,
and it will also want to know
what the starting value of y is
at that same point.
Well, there are my two
conditions.
And since this is going to have
two arbitrary constants in it,
it is these initial conditions
that will satisfy,
the arbitrary constants will
have to be picked so as to
satisfy those initial
conditions.
In some sense,
the giving of initial
conditions for a system is a
more natural activity than
giving the initial conditions of
a second order system.
You don't have to be the least
bit cleaver about it.
Anybody would give these two
numbers.
Whereas, somebody faced with a
second order system might
scratch his head.
And, in fact,
there are other kinds of
conditions.
There are boundary conditions
you learned a little bit about
instead of initial conditions
for a second order equation.
I cannot think of any more
general terminology,
so it sounds like we are going
to actually have to get to work.
Okay, let's get to work.
I want to set up a system and
solve it.
And since one of the things in
this course is supposed to be
simple modeling,
it should be a system that
models something.
In general, the kinds of models
we are going to use when we
study systems are the same ones
we used in studying just
first-order equations.
Mixing, radioactive decay,
temperature,
the motion of temperature.
Heat, heat conduction,
in other words.
Diffusion.
I have given you a diffusion
problem for your first homework
on this subject.
What else did we do?
That's all I can think of for
the moment, but I am sure they
will occur to me.
When, out of those physical
ideas, are we going to get a
system?
The answer is,
whenever there are two of
something that there was only
one of before.
For example,
if I have mixing with two tanks
where the fluid goes like that.
Say you want to have a big tank
and a little tank here and you
want to put some stuff into the
little tank so that it will get
mixed in the big tank without
having to climb a big ladder and
stop and drop the stuff in.
That will require two tanks,
the concentration of the
substance in each tank,
therefore, that will require a
system of equations rather than
just one.
Or, to give something closer to
home, closer to this backboard,
anyway, suppose you have dah,
dah, dah, don't groan,
at least not audibly,
something that looks like that.
And next to it put an EMF
there.
That is just a first order.
That just leads to a single
first order equation.
But suppose it is a two loop
circuit.
Now I need a pair of equations.
Each of these loops gives a
first order differential
equation, but they have to be
solved simultaneously to find
the current or the charges on
the condensers.
And if I want a system of three
equations, throw in another
loop.
Now, suppose I put in a coil
instead.
What is this going to lead to?
This is going to give me a
system of three equations of
which this will be first order,
first order.
And this will be second order
because it has a coil.
You are up to that,
right?
You've had coils,
inductance?
Good.
So the whole thing is going to
count as first-order,
first-order,
second-order.
To find out how complicated it
is, you have to add up the
orders.
That is one and one,
and two.
This is really fourth-order
stuff that we are talking about
here.
We can expect it to be a little
complicated.
Well, now let's take a modest
little problem.
I am going to return to a
problem we considered earlier in
the problem of heat conduction.
I had forgotten whether it was
on the problem set or I did it
in class, but I am choosing it
because it leads to something we
will be able to solve.
And because it illustrates how
to add a little sophistication
to something that was
unsophisticated before.
A pot of water.
External temperature Te of t.
I am talking about the
temperature of something.
And what I am talking about the
temperature of will be an egg
that is cooking inside,
but with a difference.
This egg is not homogenous
inside.
Instead it has a white and it
has a yolk in the middle.
In other words,
it is a real egg and not a
phony egg.
That is a small pot,
or it is an ostrich egg.
[LAUGHTER] That is the yoke.
The yolk is contained in a
little membrane inside.
And there are little yucky
things that hold it in position.
And we are going to let the
temperature of the yolk,
if you can see in the back of
the room, be T1.
That is the temperature of the
yolk.
The temperature of the white,
which we will assume is
uniform, is going to be T2.
Oh, that's the water bath.
The temperature of the white is
T2, and then the temperature of
the external water bath.
In other words,
the reason for introducing two
variables instead of just the
one variable for the overall
temperature of the egg we had is
because egg white is liquid pure
protein, more or less,
and the T1, the yolk has a lot
of fat and cholesterol and other
stuff like that which is
supposed to be bad for you.
It certainly has different
conducting.
It is liquid,
at the beginning at any rate,
but it certainly has different
constants of conductivity than
the egg white would.
And the condition of heat
through the shell of the egg
would be different from the
conduction of heat through the
membrane that keeps the yoke
together.
So it is quite reasonable to
consider that the white and the
yolk will be at different
temperatures and will have
different conductivity
properties.
I am going to use Newton's laws
but with this further
refinement.
In other words,
introducing two temperatures.
Whereas, before we only had one
temperature.
But let's use Newton's law.
Let's see.
The question is how does T1,
the temperature of the yolk,
vary with time?
Well, the yolk is getting all
its heat from the white.
Therefore, Newton's law of
conduction will be some constant
of conductivity for the yolk
times T2 minus T1.
The yolk does not know anything
about the external temperature
of the water bath.
It is completely surrounded,
snug and secure within itself.
But how about the temperature
of the egg white?
That gets heat and gives heat
to two sources,
from the external water and
also from the internal yolk
inside.
So you have to take into
account both of those.
Its conduction of the heat
through that membrane,
we will use the same a,
which is going to be a times T1
minus T2.
Remember the order in which you
have to write these is governed
by the yolk outside to the
white.
Therefore, that has to come
first when I write it in order
that a be a positive constant.
But it is also getting heat
from the water bath.
And, presumably,
the conductivity through the
shell is different from what it
is through this membrane around
the yolk.
So I am going to call that by a
different constant.
This is the conductivity
through the shell into the
white.
And that is going to be T,
the external temperature minus
the temperature of the egg
white.
Here I have a system of
equations because I want to make
two dependent variables by
refining the original problem.
Now, you always have to write a
system in standard form to solve
it.
You will see that the left-hand
side will give the dependent
variables in a certain order.
In this case,
the temperature of the yolk and
then the temperature of the
white.
The law is that in order not to
make mistakes --
And it's a very frequent source
of error so learn from the
beginning not to do this.
You must write the variables on
the right-hand side in the same
order left to right in which
they occur top to bottom here.
In other words,
this is not a good way to leave
that.
This is the first attempt in
writing this system,
but the final version should
like this.
T1 prime,
I won't bother writing dT / dt,
is equal to --
T1 must come first,
so minus a times T1 plus a
times T2.
And the same law for the second
one.
It must come in the same order.
Now, the coefficient of T1,
that is easy.
That's a times T1.
The coefficient of T2 is minus
a minus b,
so minus (a plus b) times T2.
But I am not done yet.
There is still this external
temperature I must put into the
equation.
Now, that is not a variable.
This is some given function of
t.
And what the function of t is,
of course, depends upon what
the problem is.
So that, for example,
what might be some
possibilities,
well, suppose the problem was I
wanted to coddle the egg.
I think there is a generation
gap here.
How many of you know what a
coddled egg is?
How many of you don't know?
Well, I'm just saying my
daughter didn't know.
I mentioned it to her.
I said I think I'm going to do
a coddled egg tomorrow in class.
And she said what is that?
And so I said a cuddled egg?
She said why would someone
cuddle an egg?
I said coddle.
And she said,
oh, you mean like a person,
like what you do to somebody
you like or don't like or I
don't know.
Whatever.
I thought a while and said,
yeah, more like that.
[LAUGHTER] Anyway,
for the enrichment of your
cooking skills,
to coddle an egg,
it is considered to produce a
better quality product than
boiling an egg.
That is why people do it.
You heat up the water to
boiling, the egg should be at
room temperature,
and then you carefully lower
the egg into the water.
And you turn off the heat so
the water bath cools
exponentially while the egg
inside is rising in temperature.
And then you wait four minutes
or six minutes or whatever and
take it out.
You have a perfect egg.
So for coddling,
spelled so, what will the
external temperature be?
Well, it starts out at time
zero at 100 degrees centigrade
because the water is supposed to
be boiling.
The reason you have it boiling
is for calibration so that you
can know what temperature it is
without having to use a
thermometer, unless you're on
Pike's Peak or some place.
It starts out at 100 degrees.
And after that,
since the light is off,
it cools exponential because
that is another law.
You only have to know what K is
for your particular pot and you
will be able to solve the
coddled egg problem.
In other words,
you will then be able to solve
these equations and know how the
temperature rises.
I am going to solve a different
problem because I don't want to
have to deal with this
inhomogeneous term.
Let's use, as a different
problem, a person cooks an egg.
Coddles the egg by the first
process, decides the egg is
done, let's say hardboiled,
and then you are supposed to
drop a hardboiled egg into cold
water.
Not just to cool it but also
because I think it prevents that
dark thing from forming that
looks sort of unattractive.
Let's ice bath.
The only reason for dropping
the egg into an ice bath is so
that you could have a homogenous
equation to solve.
And since this a first system
we are going to solve,
let's make life easy for
ourselves.
Now, all my work in preparing
this example,
and it took considerably longer
time than actually solving the
problem, was in picking values
for a and b which would make
everything come out nice.
It's harder than it looks.
The values that we are going to
use, which make no physical
sense whatsoever,
but a equals 2 and b
equals 3.
These are called nice numbers.
What is the equation?
What is the system?
Can somebody read it off for
me?
It is T1 prime equals, what
is it, minus 2T1 plus 2T2.
That's good.
Minus 2T1 plus 2T2.
T2 prime is,
what is it?
I think this is 2T1.
And the other one is minus a
plus b, so minus 5.
This is a system.
Now, on Wednesday I will teach
you a fancy way of solving this.
But, to be honest,
the fancy way will take roughly
about as long as the way I am
going to do it now.
The main reason for doing it is
that it introduces new
vocabulary which everyone wants
you to have.
And also, more important
reasons, it gives more insight
into the solution than this
method.
This method just produces the
answer, but you want insight,
also.
And that is just as important.
But for now,
let's use a method which always
works and which in 40 years,
after you have forgotten all
other fancy methods,
will still be available to you
because it is method you can
figure out yourself.
You don't have to remember
anything.
The method is to eliminate one
of the dependent variables.
It is just the way you solve
systems of linear equations in
general if you aren't doing
something fancy with
determinants and matrices.
If you just eliminate
variables.
We are going to eliminate one
of these variables.
Let's eliminate T2.
You could also eliminate T1.
The main thing is eliminate one
of them so you will have just
one left to work with.
How do I eliminate T2?
Beg your pardon?
Is something wrong?
If somebody thinks something is
wrong raise his hand.
No?
Why do I want to get rid of T1?
Well, I can add them.
But, on the left-hand side,
I will have T1 prime plus T2
prime. What good is that?
[LAUGHTER]
I think you will want to do it
my way.
[APPLAUSE]
Solve for T2 in terms of T1.
That is going to be T1 prime
plus 2T1 divided by 2.
Now, take that and substitute
it into the second equation.
Wherever you see a T2,
put that in,
and what you will be left with
is something just in T1.
To be honest,
I don't know any other good way
of doing this.
There is a fancy method that I
think is talked about in your
book, which leads to extraneous
solutions and so on,
but you don't want to know
about that.
This will work for a simple
linear equation with constant
coefficients,
always.
Substitute in.
What do I do?
Now, here I do not advise doing
this mentally.
It is just too easy to make a
mistake.
Here, I will do it carefully,
writing everything out just as
you would.
T1 prime plus 2T1 over 2,
prime, equals 2T1 minus 5 time
T1 prime plus 2T1 over two.
I took that and substituted
into this equation.
Now, I don't like those two's.
Let's get rid of them by
multiplying.
This will become 4.
And now write this out.
What is this when you look at
it?
This is an equation just in T1.
It has constant coefficients.
And what is its order?
Its order is two because T1
prime primed.
In other words,
I can eliminate T2 okay,
but the equation I am going to
get is no longer a first-order.
It becomes a second-order
differential equation.
And that's a basic law.
Even if you have a system of
more equations,
three or four or whatever,
the law is that after you do
the elimination successfully and
end up with a single equation,
normally the order of that
equation will be the sum of the
orders of the things you started
with.
So two first-order equations
will always produce a
second-order equation in just
one dependent variable,
three will produce a third
order equation and so on.
So you trade one complexity for
another.
You trade the complexity of
having to deal with two
equations simultaneously instead
of just one for the complexity
of having to deal with a single
higher order equation which is
more trouble to solve.
It is like all mathematical
problems.
Unless you are very lucky,
if you push them down one way,
they are really simple now,
they just pop up some place
else.
You say, oh,
I didn't save anything after
all.
That is the law of conservation
of mathematical difficulty.
[LAUGHTER] You saw that even
with the Laplace transform.
In the beginning it looks
great, you've got these tables,
take the equation,
horrible to solve.
Take some transform,
trivial to solve for capital Y.
Now I have to find the inverse
Laplace transform.
And suddenly all the work is
there, partial fractions,
funny formulas and so on.
It is very hard in mathematics
to get away with something.
It happens now and then and
everybody cheers.
Let's write this out now in the
form in which it looks like an
equation we can actually solve.
Just be careful.
Now it is all right to use the
method by which you collect
terms.
There is only one term
involving T1 double prime.
It's the one that comes from
here.
How about the terms in T1
prime?
There is a 2.
Here, there is minus 5 T1
prime.
If I put it on the other side
it makes plus 5 T1 prime plus
this two makes 7 T1 prime.
And how many T1's are there?
Well, none on the left-hand
side.
On the right-hand side I have 4
here minus 10.
4 minus 10 is negative 6.
Negative 6 T1 put on this
left-hand side the way we want
to do makes plus 6 T1.
There are no inhomogeneous
terms, so that is equal to zero.
If I had gotten a negative
number for one of these
coefficients,
I would instantly know if I had
made a mistake.
Why?
Why must those numbers come out
to be positive?
It is because the system must
be, the system must be,
fill in with one word,
stable.
And why must this system be
stable?
In other words,
the long-term solutions must be
zero, must all go to zero,
whatever they are.
Why is that?
Well, because you are putting
the egg into an ice bath.
Or, because we know it was
living but after being
hardboiled it is dead and,
therefore, dead systems are
stable.
That's not a good reason but it
is, so to speak,
the real one.
It's clear anyway that all
solutions must tend to zero
physically.
That's obvious.
And, therefore,
the differential equation must
have the same property,
and that means that its
coefficients must be positive.
All its coefficients must be
positive.
If this weren't there,
I would get oscillating
solutions, which wouldn't go to
zero.
That is physical impossible for
this egg.
Now the rest is just solving.
The characteristic equation,
if you can remember way,
way back in prehistoric times
when we were solving these
equations, is this.
And what you want to do is
factor it.
This is where all the work was,
getting those numbers so that
this would factor. So it's
r plus 1 times r plus 6
And so the solutions are,
the roots are r equals
negative 1.
I am just making marks on the
board, but you have done this
often enough,
you know what I am talking
about.
So the characteristic roots are
those two numbers.
And, therefore,
the solution is,
I could write down immediately
with its arbitrary constant as
c1 times e to the negative t
plus c2 times e to the negative
6t. Now, I have got to get T2.
Here the first worry is T2 is
going to give me two more
arbitrary constants.
It better not.
The system is only allowed to
have two arbitrary constants in
its solution because that is the
initial conditions we are giving
it.
By the way, I forgot to give
initial conditions.
Let's give initial conditions.
Let's say the initial
temperature of the yolk,
when it is put in the ice bath,
is 40 degrees centigrade,
Celsius.
And T2, let's say the white
ought to be a little hotter than
the yolk is always cooler than
the white for a soft boiled egg,
I don't know,
or a hardboiled egg if it
hasn't been chilled too long.
Let's make this 45.
Realistic numbers.
Now, the thing not to do is to
say, hey, I found T1.
Okay, I will find T2 by the
same procedure.
I will go through the whole
thing.
I will eliminate T1 instead.
Then I will end up with an
equation T2 and I will solve
that and get T2 equals blah,
blah, blah.
That is no good,
A, because you are working too
hard and, B, because you are
going to get two more arbitrary
constants unrelated to these
two.
And that is no good.
Because the correct solution
only has two constants in it.
Not four.
So that procedure is wrong.
You must calculate T2 from the
T1 that you found,
and that is the equation which
does it.
That's the one we have to have.
Where is the chalk?
Yes.
Maybe I can have a little thing
so I can just carry this around
with me.
That is the relation between T2
and T1.
Or, if you don't like it,
either one of these equations
will express T2 in terms of T1
for you.
It doesn't matter.
Whichever one you use,
however you do it,
that's the way you must
calculate T2.
So what is it?
T2 is calculated from that pink
box.
It is one-half of T1 prime plus
T1.
Now, if I take the derivative
of this, I get minus c1 times
the exponential.
The coefficient is minus c1,
take half of that,
that is minus a half c1
and add it to T1.
Minus one-half c1 plus c1 gives
me one-half c1.
And here I take the derivative,
it is minus 6 c2.
Take half of that,
minus 3 c2 and add this c2 to
it, minus 3 plus 1 makes minus
2.
That is T2.
And notice it uses the same
arbitrary constants that T1
uses.
So we end up with just two
because we calculated T2 from
that formula or from the
equation which is equivalent to
it, not from scratch.
We haven't put in the initial
conditions yet,
but that is easy to do.
Everybody, when working with
exponentials,
of course, you always want the
initial conditions to be when T
is equal to zero
because that makes all the
exponentials one and you don't
have to worry about them.
But this you know.
If I put in the initial
conditions, at time zero,
T1 has the value 40.
So 40 should be equal to c1 +
c2.
And the other equation will say
that 45 is equal to one-half c1
minus 2 c2.
Now we are supposed to
solve these.
Well, this is called solving
simultaneous linear equations.
We could use Kramer's rule,
inverse matrices,
but why don't we just
eliminate.
Let me see.
If I multiply by,
45, so multiply by two,
you get 90 equals c1
minus 4 c2.
Then subtract this guy from
that guy.
So, 40 taken from 90 makes 50.
And c1 taken from c1,
because I multiplied by two,
makes zero.
And c2 taken from minus 4 c2,
that makes minus 5 c2,
I guess.
I seem to get c2 is equal to
negative 10.
And if c2 is negative 10,
then c1 must be 50.
There are two ways of checking
the answer.
One is to plug it into the
equations, and the other is to
peak.
Yes, that's right.
[LAUGHTER]
The final answer is,
in other words,
you put a 50 here,
25 there, negative 10 here,
and positive 20 there.
That gives the answer to the
problem.
It tells you,
in other words,
how the temperature of the yolk
varies with time and how the
temperature of the white varies
with time.
As I said, we are going to
learn a slick way of doing this
problem, or at least a very
different way of doing the same
problem next time,
but let's put that on ice for
the moment.
And instead I would like to
spend the rest of the period
doing for first order systems
the same thing that I did for
you the very first day of the
term.
Remember, I walked in assuming
that you knew how to separate
variables the first day of the
term, and I did not talk to you
about how to solve fancier
equations by fancier methods.
I instead talked to you about
the geometric significance,
what the geometric meaning of a
single first order equation was
and how that geometric meaning
enabled you to solve it
numerically.
And we spent a little while
working on such problems because
nowadays with computers it is
really important that you get a
feeling for what these things
mean as opposed to just
algorithms for solving them.
As I say, most differential
equations, especially systems,
are likely to be solved by a
computer anyway.
You have to be the guiding
genius that interprets the
answers and can see when
mistakes are being made,
stuff like that.
The problem is,
therefore, what is the meaning
of this system?
Well, you are not going to get
anywhere interpreting it
geometrically,
unless you get rid of that t on
the right-hand side.
And the only way of getting rid
of the t is to declare it is not
there.
So I hereby declare that I will
only consider,
for the rest of the period,
that is only ten minutes,
systems in which no t appears
explicitly on the right-hand
side.
Because I don't know what to do
if it does up here.
We have a word for these.
Remember what the first order
word was?
A first order equation where
there was no t explicitly on the
right-hand side,
we called it,
anybody remember?
Just curious.
Autonomous, right.
This is an autonomous system.
It is not a linear system
because these are messy
functions.
This could be x times y
or x squared minus 3y squared
divided by sine of x plus y.
It could be a mess.
Definitely not linear.
But autonomous means no t.
t means the independent
variable appears on the
right-hand side.
Of course, it is there.
It is buried in the dx/dt and
dy/dt.
But it is not on the right-hand
side.
No t appears on the right-hand
Because no t appears on the
right-hand side,
I can now draw a picture of
this.
But, let's see,
what does a solution look like?
I never even talked about what
a solution was,
did I?
Well, pretend that immediately
after I talked about that,
I talked about this.
What is the solution?
Well, the solution,
maybe you took it for granted,
is a pair of functions,
x of t, y of t if when
you plug it in
it satisfies the equation.
And so what else is new?
The solution is x
equals x of t,
y equals y of t.
If I draw a picture of that
what would it look like?
This is where your previous
knowledge of physics above all
18.02, maybe 18.01 if you
learned this in high school,
what is x equals x of t and
y equals y of t?
How do you draw a picture of
that?
What does it represent?
A curve.
And what will be the title of
the chapter of the calculus book
in which that is discussed?
Parametric equations.
This is a parameterized curve.
So we know what the solution
looks like.
Our solution is a parameterized
curve.
And what does a parameterized
curve look like?
Well, it travels,
and in a certain direction.
Okay.
That's enough.
Why do I have several of those
curves?
Well, because I have several
solutions.
In fact, given any initial
starting point,
there is a solution that goes
through it.
I will put in possible starting
points.
And you can do this on the
computer screen with a little
program you will have,
one of the visuals you'll have.
It's being made right now.
You put down starter point,
put down a click,
and then it just draws the
curve passing through that
point.
Didn't we do this early in the
term?
Yes.
But there is a difference now
which I will explain.
These are various possible
starting points at time zero for
this solution,
and then you see what happens
to it afterwards.
In fact, through every point in
the plane will pass a solution
curve, parameterized curve.
Now, what is then the
representation of this?
Well, what is the meaning of x
prime of t and y prime of t?
I am not going to worry for the
moment about the right-hand
side.
What does this mean by itself?
If this is the curve,
the parameterized motion,
then this represents its
velocity vector.
It is the velocity of the
solution at time t.
If I think of the solution as
being a parameterized motion.
All I have drawn here is the
trace, the path of the motion.
This hasn't indicated how fast
it was going.
One solution might go whoosh
and another one might go rah.
That is a velocity,
and that velocity changes from
point to point.
It changes direction.
Well, we know its direction at
each point.
That's tangent.
What I cannot tell is the
speed.
From this picture,
I cannot tell what the speed
was.
Too bad.
Now, what is then the meaning
of the system?
What the system does,
it prescribes at each point the
velocity vector.
If you tell me what the point
(x, y) is in the plane then
these equations give you the
velocity vector at that point.
And, therefore,
what I end up with,
the system is what you call in
physics and what you call in
18.02 a velocity field.
So at each point there is a
certain vector.
The vector is always tangent to
the solution curve through
there, but I cannot predict from
just this picture what its
length will be because at some
points, it might be going slow.
The solution might be going
slowly.
In other words,
the plane is filled up with
these guys.
Stop me.
Not enough here.
So on and so on.
We can say a system of first
order equations,
ODEs of first order equations,
autonomous because there must
be no t on the right-hand side,
is equal to a velocity field.
A field of velocity.
The plane covered with velocity
vectors.
And a solution is a
parameterized curve with the
right velocity everywhere.
Now, there obviously must be a
connection between that and the
direction fields we studied at
the beginning of the term.
And there is.
It is a very important
connection.
It is too important to talk
about in minus one minute.
When we need it,
I will have to spend some time
talking about it then.